rischio incendi a casa di willwoosh e
ragazzi miei ragazzi internet e nella
puntata di cucina buttata nella puntata
di oggi come in tante altre puntate ci
facciamo sempre la stessa domanda perché
farlo piccolo quando puoi farlo gigante
abbiamo fatto orio hamburger fetta al
latte giganti adesso è arrivato il
momento di fare una delle cose che mi
piace di più al mondo fare qualcosa di
gigante può portare a renderla più buona
e altre volte in realtà le dimensioni
non contano oggi proveremo a fare un
muffin gigante mettiamoci subito
all'opera per fare un mafia in gigante
avremo bisogno di 4 v fa 530 grammi di
farina 270 grammi di zucchero 270 grammi
di latte intero 250 g di burro morbido
200 tra mi di gocce di cioccolato
fondente che andremo a creare due buste
di vanillina bicarbonato sale fino e 20
grammi di lievito in polvere per dolci
per prima cosa prendete il burro e
mettetelo all'interno di una grandissima
ciotola fatto quel punto dobbiamo
mangiare se queste possiamo dirlo sono
le fruste più inutili della storia io
vorrei quelli doppia perché è meglio
singoli perché simile doppia mi trovo
queste sono le fruste migliori della
storia diamo il benvenuto a giulia nella
nostra cucina
giulia benvenuto nella nostra cucina in
onore per me e ragazze seri con i
presenti aggiungiamo a questo punto lo
zucchero è un po duri noto come posso
fare
ronde fatto tutto ciò che era ormai si è
fatto poco e 10 secondi vai vai
cominciamo a fallire da subito sia per
chi non lo sapesse una pasticceria
diventa qui perché vuole vedere come
falliamo ogni volta ho il terrore di
mettere cosa ormai microonde
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma passione amore va bene ragazzi
effetto però dai frullo ma passano tutte
le parti e normale creiamo una struttura
perché io non accolgo questa struttura
si chiama paraschizzi mammamia guarda
che ha creato dividere per una
telecamera che cosa è creato e che ti
sei nascondendo a vedere bisogna avere
un impatto è morto a questo punto
aggiungiamo le uova anzi le uova e wolf
ad una perché una volta perché così non
si slegano gli ingredienti giusti centro
sempre succede con la tutto che te frega
niente andata toccante al 32 scossette
diuof armi però con le bucce comuni
adesso aggiungiamo farina e lievito
giulia giusto no comment
aspettate qualcosa non quadra questa
farina non verrà mai inglobata
aggiungiamo la vanillina lena al musée d
autore buonissimo ha un odore buonissimo
vecchio lo scoraggia a come giudicare
infine una parola l'umorismo di enrico
fecero ma è un critico il tuo
scrivete qua sotto un commento per
l'umorismo di enrico l'umorismo di
gianmarco io direi il sopraffino il mio
sabotaggio gianmarco som pal viene
voglia di mangiarlo anche se sul burro e
zucchero sul tipo di informazione seria
unire insieme tutte le polveri quindi
farina bicarbonato e lievito così almeno
si amalgameranno meglio all'impasto e
qui hanno non l'ha fatto non lo ha fatto
prepareremo per via per giocare la
giornata giorgio mettiamo un pizzico di
sale un pizzico di sale
un pizzicotto rimanere dove un
pizzicotto aggiungiamo il latte a filo
un po più defilata glielo come vietati
anni e più che altro per una cosa perché
penso a quanto sarebbero buon ogni tipo
20 qua ma una mamma mia la tua sarebbero
buoni mezzi 4 ma fin invece che 1 le
norme si venuto di me perché verrà di me
è meglio di me perché ti va pero di 176
quanto qualsiasi forma o bene partire
con 165 eve al massimo si alza
leggermente aggiungiamo le gocce di
cioccolato ma molte tagli invito come se
io tagli una delle mie ditte tenendo a
cercare gli altri anni ha avuto un
peggioramento è nell'elaborare i
pensieri e banalmente
forse un logopedista non confermata ieri
a ragazzi come ha detto giulia una parte
di queste gocce che direi scaglie di
cioccolato troppo grandi che saranno
perfetti fidati
mammamia gianmarco che era il momento di
impegnare a finirlo rapido indolore
falsi un dolore è da vedere ho un'idea
però ragazzi dovete seguirmi di lattaia
ad una cosa ciao faticato a sta
cambiando la faccio il perimetro è
fissato queste forbici quanto gli piace
fare il meccanico non sanno fare con voi
cosa fareste con una spada il silenzio
da queste dunque ma di cui a versare il
composto da fuori sulle tue mani che
mette pure un indovinello banale e
personaggio di harry potter solo
malocchio da per lì che cambia forma a
seconda delle tue paure nobile steso la
mia spalla
no eccola incammina esatto e personaggio
di harry potter e topi del fondo mesti
costabile vorrei creare avete presente
che i muffin c'hanno quella cartina
attorno a fare league ricette stessa
cosa avrà tutto pazzo lo sai che ci
mette una vita
io l'ho fatto con i cappelli di
testuggine culinaria ci ho messo una
vita dello perlomeno testimone a russo
non è semplicissimo perché ti fai il
titolo 3 green se in un arabo ci metterà
in bella vista meno di un minuto che
etico è molto bravo e come faiola dargli
la forma conica
allora credo in questo progetto ho
intravisto un muffin enorme lì dentro è
personaggio del signore degli anelli
sono la nimbus 2000 signore degli anelli
la torre di sauro non alcuno dei nove
cavaliere identico proprio questo è il
massimo che si può fare è ora che
versiamo in pasto gli diamo la forma io
prevedo ragazzi
ma non seria come la sciagura anno e
possiamo fare questo andiamo l'anarchico
che cosa vuole fare sta incollando un po
leggermente potrebbe funzionare
ho intravisto le norme ma fin qui sono i
ragazzi guardatelo intravedi iniziamo
subito a riempirlo in modo che capitò
pareggiamo un pochino tagliamo bravo
mettiamo sopra le gocce e a questo punto
direi di infornare 165 gradi per andiamo
occhio un tetto per te l'ho con 40
minuti però già venti minuti vediamo che
cosa sta succedendo
un secondo solo di attenzione vorrei
condividere con voi una cosa stiamo
aspettando che il muffin si cuocia e
jamal carico sono usciti a prendere il
pranzo nel frattempo i due geni e
giustamente hanno lasciato le chiavi a
casa mia visto che io ero all'interno
della mia casa e aspetto un pacco mi
hanno chiuso in balcone quindi non
riesco a entrare in casa e loro non
potranno entrare visto che lì che vi
stanno con tenterò quindi il muffin che
oltre quella serranda chiusa per via
dell'illuminazione è spacciato quel
muffin prima che è ricordato a prendere
il doppione che sta a casa di mia mamma
ciao spacciato io entro che brucia io
non so come entrare in casa e non so
cosa stiano facendo loro in questo
momento non oso immaginare che tocca le
rischio incendio a casa the whale watch
ragazzi miei perdonatemi la ripresa ma
sto guidando è successo un delirio
stavamo girando ora cucinate già ma qui
siamo lucidi caso che la parte meno
parlamentari insieme i balconi e
giammarco la testa e si trova a matisse
i barconi sbaglio quindi una possibilità
quando mi chiamò chiuso alcune
coltellate qui prende fuoco tutto è un
disastro probabilmente cielo chiuso io
perché sono io che sono uscito l'ha
fatto voi quei gesti inconsci non ha
sulla testa proprio nel qualcuno quanto
radicata noi non possiamo entrare
stiamo citando una città diventata è in
forno sto andando a piedi verso casa di
cui erano enrico al corso a casa sua a
prendere il doppione però gli esplode a
casa quel poveraccio etica valide casa
de guglielmo che va a fuoco non possiamo
mangiare ma solo quasi arrivato mamma
mia comunque quando devono succedere
certe cose e ricoh lo aveva detto se
prenderci le chiavi no non le abbiamo
prese poi succedono queste cose assurde
ragazzi miei una situazione disastrosa
qui fai bene ma in cucina tutto bene
nella ricetta
[Musica]
mammamia enrico io spero che enrico voli
sono arrivato a casa a prezzo presto
fatti nei suoi fan
ok chiami di guglielmo prese ma qui ne
sto arrivando provato scorsi ma niente
adesso sono solo delle mani di enrico si
deve assolutamente sbrigare il delirio
sono quasi arrivato da guglielmo sembra
che sia tutto in ordine per adesso
quindi la situazione meno grave di quel
che si pensasse
ho sentito enrico è praticamente
arrivato è venuto qui per salvarci corri
richiamo questo popolo
vediamo se quella giusta comprendere se
[Musica]
c'è un odore buonissimo marco devi
smetterla di mettere la testa negli
altri posti che non c'erano sopra le
spalle per non dare amaro quelle cose
che uno fa inconsciamente la cosa
assurda è che nonostante siano arrivati
dopo non so quanto è ancora tutto crudo
quindi dovremo ancora aspettare però c'è
un buon odore vogliono un ottimo d'ore
speriamo che venga bene anche se non è
lievitato come volevamo noi ci siamo
perfetto dopo tanta attesa neanche uno
ma dobbiamo riuscire a fare ma non è
venuto il cupolone
forse perché se n'è andata giulia e
quindi abbiamo perso quella vera
scintilla dei rapiti toso ha un odore e
c'è un valore molto buono allora muffin
è una torta giulia diventa e così fu
si è stato da dove visse formare
studioso mancando due fame svuotiamo
come per terra qui dove vuoi farci
piatto presine non lo prendi pappone
no perché vorrei vedere due mani ma pone
una mano no non lo prendo
[Musica]
vediamo gli habitat la vita la vita
media la moglie abita che vivono nel
mare ingegnosi bravo devo prendere con
le mani su cosa è marchi e mezzo ha
marchiato l'anima hai detto il vero moon
questa frase già macchiato di realtà
visto così da fuori
[Risate]
nel frattempo come sempre vi invitiamo a
mettere un like questo video un bel
pollice in su soprattutto per il rigore
è stato velocissimo a prendere le chiavi
iscriviti che questo canale perché porta
una fortuna a tutte le nostre persone
che si sono iscritte hanno ricevuto le
grandi soddisfazione perché lasciateci
un commento facendoci sapere qual è
un'altra cosa che vorreste vedere fatta
gigante siamo curiosi era intento a
cottura a esser soffice sembra soffici
cotto che credo è stato un ora dentro
aprirono acqua vuole nostra favore
facendo enormi
pronte le mappe in gigante ha un sapore
così a primo acchitto come quesito
assaggiarlo che è bob crisi mi piace
pure a me manco masticato ma cosa a
capirlo credi sa cosa mi piace molto
l'esterno sepolcro canto zoe l'interno
un po tenda sbriciolarsi però mamma mia
che si sbriciola nello stomaco mais
bruciatore papa non ha chiuso fuori
secondo me necessitava di più gocce di
cioccolato non so voi cosa ne pensate
io ho trovato giusto è morto e lei
stessa gara 3 non come la prima cioè nel
senso proprio piccolo perché un conto è
non è sembrata leggerissimo campo ha
sbriciolato e vero disastro per noi cell
emerso non è stato più in grado di
chiudersi un balcone da solo
so che c'è niente da voi espresso un
pensiero senza merico su questi terzo ma
di ancora no
lo tengo in mano che valore abbia mostra
video 1 2 tv con un nuovo abusiva
buttata grazie
[Risate]
maurizio attesa
in testa